do believe you know you're rocking the
cape again you're rocking the suit
um let me read you a few tweets because
there's a lot of great reactions out
there for you kumasar Cody says there
should be a contract to make Henry
Cavill the only actor to act Superman it
just feels right when he acts it the
real soup says I'm still on a high he
looked perfect this moment seemed
impossible only a couple months ago but
when the world needed him most he
returned and finally Farah 7016 says I
still can't believe that Henry Cavill is
back at Superman if someone pinched me
please if I am dreaming so you've read
some of these you've even reached out to
fans over the ground to give them you
know I'm back but how much does this
motivate you to hop back into this
iconic character that you took on for
the first time nearly 10 years ago I
think the most important thing for any
of this it's anyone who needs to uh don
the cape to to be the custodian of a
character like this uh the primary point
is if the fans want them there and honey
they wanted you there if if they and if
that is the case then I it's it's my
honor my privilege to to be that and
it's my duty to make sure that I do them
justice as the custodian the character
maybe a little bit more
well I think you most definitely have
and you will continue to absolutely we
look forward to seeing that in the past
though you have said that there is
enough Superman out there for a
multitude of folks to John this red cape
so if that is the case who is another
celebrity that you would like to see
take on this character on the big screen
outside of yourself that's not for me to
say yes it is if you've thrown it out
there in the past of course I have but
that's not for me to say exactly who
okay but in your humble opinion in my
humble opinion I will tell you one day
[Music]
Dare I ask
well Enola homes too I think I might
like it better than the first one to be
perfectly honest oh good what do you
like about it well I love that you and
your sis were just really collaborating
and there's there's comedy that ensues
there but also like tender moments and
of course like this the suspense crack
in the case and you guys are going at it
together on a case so what is it like
exactly working with Miss Millie Millie
is fantastic yeah clearly a bombastic
energy that much is obvious and also an
incredibly Keen mind it's really a
really good producer she's a very very
smart she makes very astute decisions
and choices on set and it's wonderful to
see I am looking forward to watching her
career continue to Greater Heights as it
grows I know I mean she's already
started off on like such a platform and
to see her as a producer as well it's
just like wow at such a young age is
what is something about Millie that
might surprise us because I feel like
you know fans think oh we know
everything there is to know Millie's
always quite quite open with everything
and so I don't think there's anything I
could say that would surprise you and
she said you were quite secretive I was
like well did you know know anything
about Superman what gives I did not know
I really did it I really didn't but I I
will tell you he is so talented so no
wonder they want him back so that might
make you a good detective do you think
you would be a good detective in real
life
um would I be a good detective I'm not
entirely sure I do like to get to the
bottom of things I do like to work stuff
out I like to know the why of things and
which can be a good thing and a bad
thing yes it can be a little bit
frustrating sometimes for myself uh
teach myself to let things go be like I
just won't know what happened there
um but yeah it's uh could I be a good
detective probably not really after all
that Henry yeah but I think it takes
more than just that I think there's a
certain skill set required and that
probably takes years to build
I wonder who told you to fight like that
another thing our mother has to answer
for these action scenes that we see were
you surprised that it was taking on this
kind of turn of events when it comes to
action sequences no I think it's a key
piece because everyone was was gasping
and making all the right noise at the
right time and that's what you want in a
third act you want people feeling that
and so that little piece of action uh
did the job and I I think it did it very
well and it's got all the feels it's got
a Touch of Romance yes it's got got some
action it's got this brother sister like
love hate kind of thing going on we get
introduced to someone else who could
definitely carry on this franchise so
could an Ola homes 3 exists without
Sherlock Holmes well first off it's
always been another story and absolutely
anola homes can exist without Sherlock I
think that's one of the key messages of
the movie actually
and
having said that if a another movie
happens and if everything aligns and I'm
wanted back then it would obviously be a
great honor and an opportunity for me to
jump in so
we'll discuss that when the time comes
season three coming up for us fans are
over the moon and I love how you kind of
like nerd out too as you're connecting
with the fans I mean you really get into
it you you connect with them on an
entirely different level do you have a
message for The Witcher season three
fans and what they can't anticipate it's
difficult to give too much away uh but I
I had the opportunity to work with
Wolfgang stageman again Wolfgang
stagerman is the stunt coordinator and
him and I work together really really
well we designed fights together we
build all this stuff together when we
shoot it we work amazingly together he
is extraordinary at what he does he has
such a genius brain for building fights
and his team is extraordinary as well
and there is plenty of action in season
three and uh hopefully it all comes
together perfectly in the edit
foreign